okay so then the other day Hannah was
like if we were long distance any longer
I think you could go get a jack off
massage and I was like I don't even
really like jack off massages and she
goes yeah but you could get one if you
want Oh fast forward to today hey man
can I jack you off a little bit
I could get a jackoff massage
you could jack me off but I won't kiss
you oh this is for business ah is that
also inadvertently making it okay for
her no
if I was proposed a business proposal
and then I'm like okay what you can do
no you can touch my wiener and jack me
off okay if him responding to that
that's not on the table hey I can help
get you more customers I'll give you
okay touch my dick
that's good